quand on fait de l'humour et qu'on écrit
sur des sujets graves forcément ça
devient de l'humour noir parce qu'on
voilà on parle de choses qui sont qui
sont sérieuses et qui sont parfois
tragiques j'avais vraiment cette envie
de dénoncer des choses tout en le
pratiquant si tu montes et ça c'est
quelque chose qui m'a jamais quitté et
là dans ce deuxième spectacle on
retrouve encore ça même si je parle
d'autres sujets mais on reste toujours
dans ce truc de dénoncer des injustices
des discriminations et de le sujet en
tout cas qui moi me toucher
personnellement et dont j'avais envie de
parler quand j'ai commencé à écrire je
me rendais pas forcément compte que
c'était l'humour noir en fait je me
rendais pas forcément compte ce qui
trash c'est juste mon humour et c'est
quand je voyais les la tête des gens
parfois dans la salle il faisait comme
ça je me disais ok donc c'est quand même
un humour qu'il faut choquer quand il me
voit il voit une blonde qui a l'air un
petit peu innocente et puis en fait il
s'attend pas du tout à cet hiver là et
si tu viens mon spectacle n'était pas du
tout prévu tu peux quand même te
prendre une petite claque